hey i'm eddie wu and i'm super excited
to be with you today from the powerhouse
museum
where we're not just in any exhibition
we're in the exhibition for matin
australia's guitar and there's a
phenomenal number of instruments here
that i'm really delighted to be able to
unpack with you with damian mcdonald who
is the curator for this exhibition damon
great to see you thank you thank you so
much for joining us now these
instruments
are amazing matin is a really important
australian
uh instrument maker can you tell us a
bit about this exhibition and why it
matters
so mayton is an australian company
australian guitar company
and they make guitars out of australian
timber
and the founder bill may he started
making guitars out of australian timber
try and find
a native timber that would work with
guitars
and he has found a couple as it turns
out
australian blackwood and queensland
maple are both
woods that are still used in mate and
guitars he started
the company back in 1946 wow so he was a
he was a woodwork teacher so carpenter
by trade man after my own heart
education his heart exactly yeah and he
was he was an educationalist as well
but he's he really wanted to make
instruments so his wife urged him to
to leave his job as a teacher and just
concentrate on making instruments
uh and that's what he's kept doing and
what a wealth of instruments we can see
here i mean
even just standing back and looking at
the small section here there's such
variety
in these different instruments i noticed
that not only do we have these
you know 6 and 12 string guitars over
here but these
i mean this particular instrument here
is enormous it's not a
16 guitar it's a bass guitar can you
tell us a little bit about these
instruments
so this is this one's quite interesting
because because of the physics in it so
it's a bass guitar so the low notes in
the musical register
so big thick strings to create that low
note
uh very very long scale to create
you know a long note which is the the
bottom end notes
and also for those who maybe don't play
an instrument themselves
the the longer the note is that's the
deeper sound that it creates which is
why we're thinking about bases right
yeah right and what was the other thing
you're going to point out i was just
going to point out the construction of
the body
so a really big resonant body so
the bigger the the body the deeper the
sound
or the more resonance it can create with
a lower note
fantastic so as we look across some of
these instruments again
fantastic variety here um i wonder if
you could tell us a bit about you know
bill may he didn't just want to make
guitars copying you know
fender or gibson he wanted to be quite
characteristically strange you talked
about the materials
can you say more about the designs and
how they're distinctive yeah so
so bill he wasn't interested in getting
into the market to make copies of
established guitars
particularly fender gibson guitars
he wanted to create his own unique
australian guitars so
he did a lot of experimentation with the
shapes of the guitars
where the pickups would be the
microphonic part that
amplifies the strings um different
configurations of where the knobs would
go and
and each of the instruments is quite
unique so they're all handmade as well
so
from 1946 up until now the guitars will
be made in the factory today are still
handmade so they're very unique guitars
but yeah he wanted to create a unique
australian guitar so
that's why there's so much such a
variety of guitars in this collection
and that artistry it's pretty on show
when you have a look at these much
smaller instruments
these are ukuleles i think of matan
making guitars
i didn't even realize originally that he
made these yeah so bill may was he loved
hawaiian music
so back in the 40s he played hawaiian
music he'd made a number of ukes for
himself and
for his friends uh so that's actually
what he started making the first
instruments
in instruments that bill may made were
ukuleles
and something that that's interesting
about ukuleles is the different shapes
so this one up the top here i noticed
doesn't have the shape of a guitar which
sort of tapers in
it's kind of well it's a sort of
pineapple shape isn't it that's right
it's a pineapple that's what they're
called they're actually called pineapple
ukes
and they're they come from hawaii so
ukuleles are a hawaiian instrument
and the traditional hawaiians made them
in the shape of a pineapple
and when the europeans visited hawaii
and and loved the sound of the ukulele
as well they adopted it but
their idea of a stringed instrument
acoustic streaming
instrument was the spanish guitar so
that's why we've got ukuleles in that
shape so
concert ukuleles and pineapple utility
so the geometry underneath these of
these different shapes are actually
culturally significant as well yeah and
there are instruments here that i mean
if i have a look at these guys here
most people would not even think that
these are guitars could you describe to
people who've never seen an instrument
like this before what are we looking at
how's it even played
so this is a lap steel guitar so and it
is different
different to a guitar so you don't play
it
like that strip strumming it while
you're holding it this one
is set up like a little table so there's
legs attached to the bottom of it
uh and you sit underneath it and instead
of strumming and
fretting the the the notes this one you
actually use a metal slide
um and you'll see on here that the
strings are really far off that
that fretboard they're very highly
raised aren't they that's right so i on
a guitar you press down on the strings
it presses on a particular part of the
guitar neck
which changes the note these ones just
the strings
you know they're tuned differently but
you change the pitch of it by sliding
that little slide on
on the guitar and people would have
heard it in country and western songs
that very
sad kind of sound is usually a slide
guitar
absolutely now we've been talking about
all these instruments but i'm actually
even more interested about your life as
a curator you know creating something
like this
obviously there's a whole team of people
involved i'm really interested in
what are the different kinds of skills
that contribute to this and also
what are the numbers and mathematics
under creating an exhibition
right so there's a there's a big team
there's a big team at the museum that
put on these exhibitions so
uh i'm the curator so i come up with the
ideas
uh i research the things that we want to
put into the collection
and into exhibitions so for this one
i researched the guitars had a look at
the guitars we'd like to display
selected the ones that that represent
the story the best way
and then we we get a team of people who
look after the collection so we have
registrars and conservatives registrars
are the people who
um care for the the objects when they
come to the museum
conservators are the people who care for
the material so
if something's damaged they repair it or
they make sure that it doesn't get
damaged any further
then there's designers so we have
designers and there's a lot of
mathematics involved in design
so we have graphic designers who who
create all the graphics that are in
exhibitions so the signage and all the
labels
and of course there's maths that goes
into that so they have to make sure that
it fits in the particular space and all
the letters
look neat legible of a particular size
and then there's the exhibition designer
so
that's that's like an architect really
or an interior designer
and what that person does is look at all
the objects that we've picked
and then that person places them uh in a
plan of the exhibition space
and that's really where the maths comes
into it so in this particular display
we have a 42 meter long wall of guitars
now guitars all have their own
dimensions so we took dimensions of all
the guitars
and then we worked out what's the best
way to fit these on a 42 meter long wall
and make them look like they're in a
pattern so
laying them out all in a straight line
because there's a lighting array that
goes with this display
and then also having a gap in between
them
that's that's equal and neat and
symmetrical
so a lot of maths that went into that so
there's a huge part of the aesthetics of
this and it
creating this visual effect actually
comes from the measurements and the
arrangement and again there's a lot of
geometry
underneath absolutely that's fantastic
are there any guitars that are really
special to you
um the one my favorite guitar in this
whole array is this one
um and it's really it's it's really the
aesthetics of it that i love so
it's called a wedgetail a mate and
wedgetail from the early 1970s
which tail you know it's a very
australian name which tail eagle
what i like about it is it's got a
particular tail
so the tailpiece of this guitar is dead
straight um
and that's quite unusual i haven't
really seen that on many uh guitars
before
and it's just got a beautiful shape to
it
and i love that sunburst design so
um the idea of of blending the colors
into a lighter
lighter shade i just love it it is a
thing of beauty now one of the things i
love about
playing the guitar is that because it's
a you know when you look at a piece of
guitar music it's actually full of
numbers i mean all musical
notes are numerical in some way but so
when you look at an actual guitar you
know tablature the numbers are there
very clearly showing you the numbers and
patterns underneath this one of things
that i think is great both you and i
actually play the guitar so teams
fitting as a way to kind of round off
and experience
this exhibition maybe we should uh come
over here and we've actually got both of
our instruments
do you want to have a bit of a jam i
reckon we should okay so i'm going to
pick this guy up and try not to
vain on the floor and um just as we're
sort of getting into here
um this these are both matin guitars
uh this is an acoustic six string and
you've got a bass
uh you know can you tell us why you've
got not just you know this kind of
guitar but this
uh so the bass guitar it it provides the
bottom end
of the sonics so in an ensemble and and
we're an ensemble of two
um the guitar is providing the mid-range
sonics
and the high sonics um so you've got
more strings on there you've got more
strings that have a higher pitch to them
the bass only has four strings but
they're much thicker
longer strings and they provide that
longer wavelength
and when they're together the different
pitch even though we might be playing
the same note there's a nice effect
chorus effect or if i'm playing a
harmony that changes the chord
completely but in an ensemble you have
a full range of sonics then with a
six-string guitar and a four-string bass
i think you know you were talking about
um harmony before and even playing the
same note but
at different octaves um many people at
home who play musical instruments are
aware of this but
for those who aren't you know we have
actually the notes of our strings
and e a d and g and they're the same
but playing different octaves the reason
they sound so melodious together
is that the waves which make up those
different sound forms
they line up the high parts line up with
the high parts
the troughs match up with the troughs
and that's what appears to our ear is
something which is
pleasing which i think is fantastic that
we can hear the mathematics
even if we don't necessarily know what's
absolutely fantastic all right well i'm
going to get my my pick out here and uh
damon do you want to count us in okay
two three four
you